Eastern Burke is a special agent from
Seattle who has been assigned to
investigate The Disappearance of two
fellow agents Evans and Kate following
the leads he along with his driver reach
a city in Idaho and start looking around
in their car unfortunately when they are
busy talking a truck suddenly Rams into
them and the screen turns black when
Ethan wakes up he finds himself in a
hospital bed in the nearby town of
wayward Pines a nurse Pamela pelcher AKA
Pam attends to him and reveals that his
driver passed away in the accident
strangely the hospital is completely
vacant and Ethan is the only patient
there he asks nurse Pam about it to
which she sarcastically replies that
people in this town never get sick then
Ethan tries to call his family but when
he asks for his belongings Pam reveals
that the local sheriff has them back in
Seattle Ethan's boss Adam informs his
wife Teresa that there's been a car
accident though the body of the driver
was identified there was not a single
trace of Ethan's remains in there
hearing this Teresa becomes upset and
she shakily shares the news with their
son Ben at the hospital Ethan repeatedly
asks for a phone so that he can contact
his family but Pam makes an excuse every
time fed up he rips at his IV puts on
his clothes and leaves despite Pam's
protests he then gets out of the
hospital premises and wanders around the
town which looks like nothing peculiar
at First Sight after a while Ethan
enters a bar where the bartender Beverly
Brown lets him use the phone he
immediately calls his wife but the phone
goes to voicemail so he simply leaves a
message before leaving the kind Beverly
hands him her address saying he can
visit her again if he needs help
following this as Ethan is walking down
the street he discovers that the
Crickets of wayward Pines are just
cricket sounds being played from
speakers this is the first indication
that this town has something very
strange going on they could at least
play some Taylor Swift the next morning
an Irate hotel clerk kicks Ethan out
when he's unable to pay for his room
with nowhere else to go he heads to the
address the bartender Beverly gave him
but finds that it's eerily abandoned
when he Ventures inside he is shocked to
discover a rotting corpse which belongs
to his friend Evans one of the special
agents he came looking for wasting no
time Ethan reaches out to the local
sheriff Arnold Pope and asks for
assistance however the Sinister cop
cross questions him about how he ended
up here Ethan explains everything and
also requests help to find the second
special agent he came looking for Kate
Hassan it turns out that Ethan and Kate
were in a romantic relationship before
she suddenly disappeared as the two
continue talking Ethan suddenly
remembers the nurse Pam mentioning that
his belongings were taken away by the
sheriff so he asks if he can have them
back but Sheriff Pope just scoffs and
asserts that he doesn't have them left
with no choice Ethan uses the sheriff's
landline and calls his family and boss
but in both cases he can only leave them
a voicemail message confused and
desperate for answers he returns to the
bar from the previous day looking for
Beverly however to his surprise the bar
owner reveals that no woman by that name
works there frustrated Ethan starts to
get aggressive but the man knocks him
out and call someone for help when Ethan
wakes up he finds himself in the
hospital once more where psychiatrist Dr
Jenkins approaches him and reveals that
the accident has left him with a
bleeding cerebrum this is why he's
experiencing disassociative breakdown
hearing this Ethan becomes enraged and
denies being delusional prompting the
devious Pam to give him a sedative she
then proceeds to take him to the surgery
room to have him operated on but
fortunately Beverly arrives in the nick
of time and takes him away together they
manage to attack nurse Pam and get out
of the hospital hiding in a cemetery
Vault before the sedative completely
knocks Ethan out Beverly tells him that
his friend Evans was killed for trying
to escape she also reveals that she
ended up in the town in 1999 almost six
months ago hearing this Ethan is left in
complete disbelief as it is now 2014 in
the real world almost 15 years after
Beverly vanished this indicates that the
time in this world Works differently
than the rest of the world several hours
later he wakes alone in the cemetery
Vault and wanders back into the town
surprisingly spots a woman who looks
like the missing agent he is looking for
his former partner and love interest
Kate she is with her husband Harold
Ballinger a local toy shop owner Ethan
covertly follows the duo to their house
and rings the doorbell at first Kate
pretends to not know him and acts
strangely but when she realizes that
Ethan is not going to play along she
Whispers they're watching us referring
to a CCTV camera hidden under the
ceiling fan Kate then reveals that she
has been living in Wayward Pines for 12
years and this is why she looks a bit
older however Ethan finds it impossible
to believe as he just met her five weeks
ago this indicates the time in Wayward
Pines seems to work differently as
people age rapidly here trying to reveal
the truth about the town Ethan tries to
bombard her with several questions but
Kate just tells them to leave saying
it's not safe here after being ignored
by his best friend and the person who he
came looking for Ethan decides he'd
better make a run for it he quickly
steals a car and attempts to flee the
mysterious town but to his surprise
after every 20 minutes he keeps on
driving back back into the town as if
it's connected in an endless loop taken
aback he gets out of the car and tries
to find an exit in the woods however he
finds a gigantic concrete wall with an
electrified fence on top the sign on the
fence warns him to return if he doesn't
want to die then we get an aerial view
of the town which turns out to be a
mountain valley surrounded by concrete
walls Ethan once again gets in the car
and tries to drive off but this time
Sheriff Pope arrives and apprehends him
just then a teen Cycles by the place and
shouts don't try and leave Mr Burke
that's rule number one rule number two
is let the sheriff wear your underwear
fortunately Ethan is released with only
a warning and he is ordered to stay
inside his hotel room he spends a few
hours there but eventually gets bored as
the place has no computers or internet
then he Ventures out and reaches the
same abandoned house where he found his
friend's body earlier surprisingly the
corpse is still there despite his having
informed the officials about it as he
investigates the scene he finds a
strange notebook in his friend's boot
but before he can keep it Sheriff Pope
arrives with a gun and scares him away
in the next scene Ethan heads to the bar
and this time Beverly is there he
explains that he wants to talk more
about his friend Evans so Beverly cranks
up the music and asks him to dance with
her she then tells him that they have to
talk quietly as there are mics under the
bar stools and to answer his question
Beverly reveals that she had also
planned to escape this wretched town
before and her accomplice was none other
than Evans he had elaborated the Escape
Plan in his notebook which was
supposedly Flawless however on the day
of his Escape he was caught and killed
hearing all this Ethan asserts that he
can find the notebook and leaves the bar
following this he goes to the Ballinger
toy shop which Kate and her husband
Harold own he confronts her alone and
demands to know what's going on but just
like the previous time Kate doesn't
reveal anything fearing that they are
being watched before Ethan leaves he
sees a notice on the door which reads a
few instructions like do not try to
leave do not discuss the past and always
answer the phone if it rings later Ethan
snakes inside the town's morgue and
successfully retrieves The Notebook from
his friend's corpse then he meets up
with Beverly and shows her the map of
the place with the help of which they
can escape hopeful Beverly agrees to
help him and removes a Tracker that has
been implanted inside his skin it turns
out that all the residents of wayward
Pines are administered with such
trackers after this they stroll through
the market where they run into the
ballingers Kate is happy that Ethan has
found a partner so she invites the two
over for dinner the next evening the
next day Ethan leaves his tracker inside
his hotel room and wanders off when he
reaches the forest to hide the runaway
supplies he notices a man shooting at
someone or something beyond the electric
fence however Ethan doesn't pay much
attention to it and leaves to meet
Beverly at cider home he explains that
the dinner is going to be the perfect
opportunity for them to escape all
Beverly has to do is enter the bathroom
and hide her tracker there so that they
can run away without a trace Beverly
agrees but she is very nervous as her
former partner Evans had also been
caught that night during dinner as the
two sets of couples are adding Ethan
gets up and heads to the bathroom to
inspect if there are any cameras
unfortunately while he is away a nervous
Beverly talks about her past life which
is a violation of the second rule she
tries to change the topic but it seems
as if the ballingers have already caught
wind of her intentions hence as soon as
Ethan returns she hides her tracker in
the bathroom and leaves with him outside
Beverly starts freaking out about the
consequences if they get caught suddenly
all the telephones in the town begin to
ring and a large mob of people comes out
to apprehend them Ethan and Beverly run
for their lives but they are soon
separated and the latter is caught
Beverly is then dragged to the Town
Square where the sheriff and a large
group is waiting for her and as Ethan
watches from a nearby building the
sheriff slices her throat saying this is
what happens when someone tries to
escape here we get to know that Beverly
was reported to the sheriff by none
other than the Ballinger couple later
Ethan shows up in Kate's Kitchen and
accuses her of participating in the
Murder She tells him that Beverly's
death was a reckoning I.E punishment for
not following the rules and as the
kettle boils Kate quietly confides that
she was forced to turn them in or else
she and her husband would get reckoned
on the other hand Ethan's wife Teresa is
worried that he hasn't returned for a
week she tries asking for help from
Ethan's boss Adam but the latter simply
informs her that they're on the case and
that it might take some time hence left
with no options Teresa and her son Ben
arrive at the Secret Service field
headquarters in Boise Idaho where Ethan
had last checked in before his
disappearance covertly logging into an
office computer Teresa finds a trail
leading them to the town of wayward
Pines however when the duo approaches
the place Sheriff Pope pulls them over
and cunningly sabotages their car under
the pretext of fixing an oil leak back
in Wayward Pines Ethan tries to escape
the place by stowing away in a milk
truck that surprisingly has a Wyoming
license plate but unfortunately he finds
himself in a space-age Supply Depot
where someone has stored the cars of
those who have found their way to
Wayward Pines Ethan also finds his
wife's damaged car among the pile which
is completely covered in dust this and
indicates that the car has been there
for quite a few years but before he can
investigate the sheriff finds him and
knocks him out with a sedative Ethan
wakes up at the hospital where nurse Pam
informs him that his family has been
discharged she also tells him about
their new home which turns out to be
Beverly's previous home wasting no time
Ethan rushes to the place and finally
reconvenes with his family however he
doesn't tell them much and again
Ventures out to find answers shortly
after he reaches the local station where
he finds nurse Pam and the sheriff in a
deep discussion Ethan immediately
confronts the sheriff for being a
criminal and the two almost get to blows
but just then the phone rings and when
Pam picks it up someone on the other
side instructs the sheriff to stand down
because of this Ethan realizes the two
are not in charge and he leaves he then
meets Kate in a secluded part of the
woods and presses her for more
information Kate reveals that she was
taken aback to find Evans in the place
but before she could interact with him
he was killed now the best way to
survive in this town is to play along as
the two continue talking Ben spots them
and is assumes that they're having an
affair he quickly rushes home and
reports it to his mother and in a fit of
rage Teresa decides to leave her husband
and the town shortly after Ethan returns
home only to find an empty house with
his wife's wedding ring on the counter
his family is walking down the road
trying to leave Wayward Pines suddenly
the sheriff arrives in his car and stops
them mentioning that no one can leave
without his permission when Ben tries to
revolt he is viciously assaulted by the
devious Sheriff but before he could
attack Teresa Ethan arrives from behind
and tackles him to the ground an intense
fight ensues which finally ends with Ben
running over the sheriff with his own
car following this Ethan shoots him dead
and grabs his keys he also finds a
remote that opens a large door in front
of them as the family gets inside the
car a frightening growl is heard and
something runs out from the other side
of the fence and grabs Sheriff Pope's
body terrified Ethan quickly shuts the
door with the remote and drives away
with his family after they again reach
Wayward Pines Ethan stops the car and
takes his son out to calm him down then
he gets inside the car and reveals
everything to his Teresa he tells her
about how the entire town is being
surveilled and that there is no way to
escape he also tells her how he ended up
here and in turn Teresa also shares her
experience meanwhile a guy approaches
Ben outside and handsome a uniform and a
letter Teresa nervously reads it which
states that Ben has to attend school
starting the next day not wanting any
trouble till a solution is found Ethan
suggests that his family play along the
next morning Ethan heads to the
Sheriff's Station to steal some guns
however as he is about to leave the
town's mayor Brad Fisher and some
photographers arrive to congratulate him
on becoming the new sheriff of the Town
it turns out that if someone kills a
person in this town they automatically
take their job position Ethan is baffled
by this but nonetheless he decides to
act along after everyone is gone Ethan
investigates the place and discovers a
secret compartment on the floor when he
opens it he finds a box which contains
all the records of the town's people to
his shock all the people including mayor
Brad were actually living in a different
city before ending up here in the
meantime nurse Pam arrives there with a
man who is supposedly committed to sin
by spraying Blasphemous words on public
property she wants the new sheriff Ethan
to reckon the man but he is adamant on
not doing that hence he says he'll take
care of it and sends her away elsewhere
Teresa and Ben arrive at the school
where they run into the head teacher
Megan Fisher she is revealed to be mayor
Brad's wife Megan quickly bonds with Ben
and takes him to the classroom promising
to take care of him during recess she
interrogates the boy and asks him some
strange questions about where he came
from it seems as if she is trying to
make Ben forget about his past life
meanwhile at the sheriff's station Ethan
talks to the criminal John and learned
that he too has become tired of the Town
John reveals that he ended up in Wayward
Pines in 2001 and from that day he has
tried to escape the place several times
but without any success as the two talk
the phone suddenly ranks and when Ethan
picks it up a woman on the other side
orders him to reckon Jon the next day at
night Ethan shares the entire ordeal
with Teresa and claims that mayor Brad
was acting strangely as if he was hiding
something hence the couple planned to
set up a dinner with the Fishers so that
they can find some information about the
place acting on the plan Teresa
approaches Megan the next morning at
school and invites her and the mayor
over for dinner at her house however the
latter wants to meet in a neutral place
so they settle for a crowded restaurant
in the market that night Ethan and
Teresa meet the Fishers where nurse Pam
the ballingers and several other
residents are all dining Teresa cleverly
takes Megan to the washroom and when
they are alone Ethan tries to press the
mayor for answers but the old man
doesn't divulge anything after the
failed dinner Ethan escorts his wife
home and then heads to the station there
he tells John to get ready as he is
letting him go free in the woods
surprisingly John doesn't want to escape
as he knows that he has very little
chance of surviving despite this Ethan
forces him to come with him the two soon
arrive near the fence which is guarded
by high voltage current and Ethan tells
Jon to go away but the latter is
hesitant he doesn't want anyone to get
in trouble because of him so he decides
to sacrifice himself he shows Ethan a
nearby hell from which one can escape
the town and then sticks himself to the
electric fence killing him instantly
although devastated Ethan returns home
with a plan in mind there he tells
Theresa everything about what happened
and in return she reveals that she's
been called up for a new job the next
morning Ethan is happy that his wife has
gained the trust of some people in the
town following this he grabs some
weapons and heads back to the forest the
episode ends as Ethan somehow scales the
Steep Hill and when he reaches the top a
mysterious humanoid-like figure lurks at
him from the Shadows to see what happens
next watch the second part in series
recapped